في هذا الخطاب قبل عام ونيف كان بوتين
عازما على تدمير من وصفهم بالنازيين الجدد
في اوكرانيا واليوم يقول الكرملين ان
العمليه صعبه ومعقده للغايه
فوفقا للمتحدث باسم الكريم
فان العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
لم تحقق كل اهدافها هذه المهمه تحققت
جزئيا لكن لا زلنا بعيدين عن تنفيذها
بصوره كامله ترون القصف بواسطه راجمات
الصواريخ قصف دونيتسك والمدن الاخرى
مستمره لذلك هناك حاجه الى ابعاد العدو
الى مسافه كبيره ولذلك ان العمليه ستستمر
في الوقت الذي كان يتحدث فيه بيسكو تقول
اوكرانيا انها حققت تقدما على الارض في
باخموت اهم بقعه من الصراع بين الجانبين
ومدينه المعركه الاطول في الحرب
الاوكرانيه بحسب قائد القوات البريه في
الجيش الاوكراني اوليكسيندرسيسكي فان
القوات الاوكرانيه شنت هجوما مضادا في
باخموت واجبرت القوات الروسيه على التراجع
في بعض الاماكن الى مسافه تصل الى كيلو
مترين فحتى مقاتلوا فاغنر وفقا لسيرسكي
استبدلوا في بعض الاماكن بوحدات من الجيش
النظامي الروسي وهي اقل استعدادا العمليه
الخاصه كما وصفها بيسكوف اجبرت روسيا على
شنها ولم تكن خيارا بسبب ما ارتكبته الدول
الغربيه من الاشياء السيئه والاخطاء
فالغرب وفقا لرجل الكريملين خدع روسيا بعد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي من خلال توسيع
البنيه التحتيه والعسكريه لحلف الناتو
باتجاه الحدود الروسيه حدود شنت موسكو
حربا من اجل تامينها لكنها باتت عرضه
للاستهداف اكثر رائد المصطفى العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات